uh is that funny all right pretty sad
but we honestly have to ask
was biden actually trying to insult the
sanders or did he actually probably
forget who the
governor of florida is now the good news
is governor desantis
he kind of kicked biden's ass this week
and set him straight
but at this point given biden's obvious
cognitive decline
it is a legitimate question either way
while biden spins in circles
with an endless stream of mixed messages
every second minute hours seemingly of
every day
governor desantis he has been consistent
no lockdowns no mask mandates no vaccine
mandates no vaccine passports
no matter what and guess what his
schools have been open for in-person
learning for an
entire year already now at least one
major sport is also
coming out against mandate got to give
props to our friend
ufc president dana white who just
announced the vaccine requirements
for the ufc fighters that's never going
to happen
and when dana says it he means it trust
me
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page and
catch our hottest interviews
and most compelling analysis you will
not get it
anywhere else